un baisser le chauffage
tes enfants tout ça si tu as envie de
les petits et puis moi je déteste dormir
avec des gens qui ont les pieds froids
vous pouvez installer un réducteur de
débit pour limiter l'usage qui vous
permet d'économiser 37 euros par an
parce qu'il faut limiter la consommation
d'eau chaude moi par exemple je prends
que des douches froides
je vous le dis que c'est très bon au
début alors je vous le dis c'est une
astuce c'est une astuce pour sportif
et je peux vous dire tu es magnifique
joueur de foot font ça
aussi
débrancher son chargeur éteindre sa box
internet la nuit débrancher son chargeur
ne permet pas d'économiser d'énergie
mais il en va différemment pour la box
internet
en fait je vais vous dire il sera aussi
propre il y a 60 je l'ai fait moi je le
lave moi je l'ai fait je l'ai fait hier
encore il avait encore 2018
soyez plus propre voilà
et couvrir les casseroles pendant la
cuisson ça réduit de quatre fois la
dépense excusez-moi d'ailleurs j'ai fait
non mais j'ai fait un ragoût aux olives
j'ai remis le couvercle et j'ai bien
passé
la cuisine exactement
[Rires]